5 54 on your wednesday morning nevada
department of transportation
well aware that that i-15 tropicana
rebuilding project
is a really big deal and that's tony
illya telling me in a zoom conversation
that whoever gets this contract is going
to have financial incentives
he explained that in real simple terms
if the contractor has 48 hours to finish
and they're able to finish in
say 24 hours then they can earn a
certain amount of money
now conversely of course should they run
late
there's also penalties attached to that
we're talking literally a quarter of a
billion dollar
undertaking tropicana has changed
dramatically over the years with
addition of the t-mobile arena and the
legion stadium
it's due for makeover now more than ever
so we are still about a year away from
the start of this proposed two-year
project there's so much more to tell you
about it so please stay tuned buckle up
drive carefully and please put down that
phone
if there is something driving you crazy
you can always email me traffic eight
at eight news now dot com alex all right
thanks so much nate five